[Music]
hi everybody i'm sarah shahi
and this is my glamour unfiltered video
[Music]
the success of the show and
you know why people have sort of really
gravitated towards it
it's because it takes a real raw look at
sexuality we're making a show about this
woman who
is in the midst of an identity crisis
and
she's a fantastic mother and she's got a
great life
but there's something missing there's
something that's just not enough and i
think it's a
it's a common thing that a lot of people
can relate to
women you know like oral and women
you know like to be fondled and this is
what it is and
this is what we expect of our partners
this is what we want
[Music]
yeah myself i've definitely been knocked
down a few times
by things and you know it just really
makes you wonder about who you are
what you want to put out into the world
especially as women
i feel like we have these stereotypes
that are put on us
by a certain age we've got to get
married and we have to have kids and
once that happens you have to dress a
certain way and you have to act a
certain way
you know you're not supposed to want sex
the way you used to have it
you know it's supposed to be this much
more tame version of your life that
you're supposed to enter
but those things don't go away and those
things still
shape who we are for me i couldn't
ignore it anymore i just wanted
something so much more
than what was in front of me and
you know there was a there was a big
freedom that happened when i turned 40
and i was just like here i am
the good the bad the ugly the insecure
i'm not going to make apologies for it
and i'm gonna put it out there and
i wouldn't trade that moment for
any part of my thirties any part of my
twenties it's a privilege to grow older
and it's a privilege to carry wisdom
with you and
one of the things i've always said is
you know i don't claim to know much
but i do know more than i did last year
[Music]
one of the things that billy the
character i play does so boldly
is she constantly is questioning where
did that other girl go
you know because she still feels it she
feels it so much and
it's a very natural cycle i think that
couples in relationships and long-term
relationships
get to as they become compliant and they
ignore each other and
you know it's like other priorities take
over i feel like through life
we have people you know that influence
us
and they tell us their opinions or they
judge us or you should be happy you've
got everything you want
you have a you know providing husband or
you have a providing wife or you have
the white picket fence or whatever it is
you know but billy is so brave and she
really encouraged me to live my life
you know boldly to the fullest because
she's saying
i have it but i'm missing something and
it's
against what her friends think you know
it's against of what
society is telling her to do but she
cannot ignore
her soul she cannot ignore that flame
inside
i've had sexist remarks being made to me
by various showrunners in my past
i don't consider myself a victim
by any means i think we have a choice we
have a choice in how we can respond to
things
[Music]
there are so many different ways to be a
feminist and a feminist
can have lots of different uh meanings
actually
it can be so big or so trivial to some
people depending on their own personal
definitions of it you have to find out
what that means for you
not what society tells you a feminist is
what is a feminist for you
[Music]
the brat scenes mostly were all in
flashback so we had to
shoot me in a way that was very
complementary
and with the cooper stuff i really just
wanted to be me
and you know there are scenes where you
can see my stomach doesn't look
100 it doesn't look great and i'm proud
of it
you know it's like i i never quite
realized the power of my body until i
had children until i breastfed
all my children now i'm i'm proud
i'm supremely proud of every stretch
mark or curve or bump or whatever it is
i earned those
for me it just goes back to to be loved
so holy
you know and by holy i mean w-h-o-l-e
that kind of you know whole to be loved
so completely
you know it makes me feel amazing and
i i truly do i wear him on my sleeve
and i'm proud of it but for myself and
my own journey
you know it's like i really had to get
to know myself i
really had to get to know the good parts
of me
the bad parts of me that's the thing
it's like no one's perfect
you know the idea that we should we
should be perfect or the idea that we
should
uh forget about our insecurities i think
is kind of insane because
it's human to question things it's human
that life is going to throw
different situations and new
circumstances at us
but if we don't dive into those
darknesses if we don't take a
true look at who we are and what those
unlikable qualities are we won't grow